at the center of AI is data it powers
everything and at Microsoft we have
unique data graphs world knowledge with
Bing and work knowledge with the rest of
the Microsoft graph but really the magic
happens when you make sense of all of
this information we've evolved from
simple searches and keyword matching to
using advanced AI techniques like
machine reading comprehension that uses
deep learning to understand the meaning
behind words we also need really
powerful hardware in order to process
these AI models like deep neural
networks we've partnered with Intel to
create industry-leading agility and
performance with FPGA chips that allow
us to read and understand billions of
documents in milliseconds so how does
this apply to your everyday today I'm
going to show you how a AI enables
intelligent search in a few ways one
with intelligent answers being for
business
intelligent image search and a new
search paradigm that is for more
conversational search let's start with
something rather mundane like finding a
movie to watch for the holidays so
instead of a simple keyword search I'm
going to use something with more natural
language like movies directed by
Spielberg starring Tom Hanks let's do
Tom Hanks okay
this answer is specific to my actual
query it filtered out TV shows and there
are other partnerships but it still
included a movie that they're doing
together in January use with beings vast
understanding of the world people and
entities and how they relate to each
other
AI enables us to power more rich and
patent complete answers now let's say
I'm doing some research on something a
bit more controversial I'm a vegan and I
take a lot of flack for my family for
being an annoying kale pusher I want to
be prepared for the inevitable holiday
table debate with my cousin so I'm gonna
do a search for facts about kale
this result here is a multi source
answer being uses AI to bring together
information from multiple different
websites into one place and at Microsoft
we believe it's important to understand
where information comes from
so although we provide quick access and
links to content we're also really
careful to make sure we also include
sources so this way I can feel confident
about my advocacy of kale and if I want
to be super prepared and understand both
sides of an issue because we don't live
in a world of absolutes I can do a query
like also using natural language like is
kale good for you this is a multi
perspective answer Bing shows alternate
viewpoints that you can understand both
sides of an issue so on one side I have
Pro kale and then the other side I have
a cautionary tale of why too much kale
is bad
so that I don't have to live in a bubble
where everything about kale is amazing
and if I really want to embrace this
kale loving lifestyle I should probably
take up yoga or pilates but I don't
actually really know the difference
between them so if I do a search for
difference between yoga and Pilates I
get this comparison answer Bing is
taking comparisons a feature typically
found in product or shopping based
scenarios and have expanded it to a
wider query set we use machine reading
comprehension to read the web and
understand entities and their aspects in
order to compare differences between
items so I think you go seems like it's
more my jam so let's go ahead and pick
that and I've heard a lot about yoga
retreats in Costa Rica so but I don't
actually have a sense for how big is
this is a relational answer in addition
to showing the actual square miles I'm
also told it's about twice the size of
Massachusetts which is incidentally my
home state so I have a good size a sense
of what that means being is taking two
used AI and add some perspective into
him for me
so not only we're using AI to search
across the billions of documents in the
web we're also using AI to make
information more understandable because
while the engineer me geeks out on all
this data the designer in me knows that
real user delight comes from making data
make sense so all of these new
experiences multiple sources multiple
perspectives comparisons and relational
answers they all make up a we call
intelligent answers so all of these
everyday ki capabilities are awesome but
what if we could apply them to the
context of work that's exactly what
we've done with Bing for business for
starters let me just go back to the Bing
homepage because I'm signed in with my
Microsoft work account at the bottom of
my home page I can see industry related
news and that's relevant to me a person
in tech and beyond this personalization
let me show you what the Microsoft graph
and AI can do for workplace productivity
so I have a Microsoft holiday party
coming up and the fabulous Harry Shum is
my executive vice president
so because I'm signed in and I think for
business enabled I type in Harry's org
and note that I'm not using his last
name but it still provides me with the
org chart for the right Harry even
though there are plenty of great Harry's
that work at Microsoft also in the same
experience our web results that are
related to the query
Harry's org so being for business brings
together the best of corporate internet
search with the best of web search all
into one experience so if I do something
a little bit more complicated like how
much vacation
do I get because of the FPGA FPGA chip I
get answers in milliseconds and if for
something supers obscure I can search
for can I hire my cousin machine reading
comprehension powers this answer what
you'll notice here is that cousin isn't
even mentioned in the passage that's
because Bing knows that cousin is a
family member and understands the
meaning behind words to get me the right
answer not that I would hire my Kaela
Hey
cousin anyway so for this holiday party
I'm also going to want to find something
festive to wear but it is a work event
so I'm gonna search for work appropriate
holiday cocktail dress and I'm gonna go
to image or image vertical and then this
one looks appropriately festive Bing
intelligent image uses computer vision
and AI technique in order to find
dresses that look just like this one
with direct links to buy so they can
look around and do some price
comparisons and the other thing it does
is our object detection allows me to
Reese cope this query on just this
necklace so now I can find necklaces
that look very similar to one in this
photo again with direct links to buy
being is intelligent search that saves
time and money okay indecision to
intelligent answers Bing for business
and intelligent image search we're also
using AI to make the search box itself
more conversational with an interactive
guided search experience we hear a lot
from customers that they wished search
could just complete their sentences if I
do a vague search like I'm feeling
stressed which may or may not be because
of this demo I get this guided web
guided search experience so I get
obviously the web results you'd expect
from a search engine I get our answers
but then up the top what you'll see here
is that it prompts for additional query
refinement so I can go through and pick
stress management and then breathing
exercises and then I can also kind of
expand to see my previous results what's
different here is that search is
building upon the last search so it's a
little bit more conversational a little
bit more personalized we're able to do
with this is get you better answers
faster this is a new search paradigm we
are amplifying our extensive knowledge
graph with a I our expertise in
conversational AI with our box like
shall I sands o are brought together
with our vast data enable enables thing
to create a new interactive search
experience that gets you better answers
faster if I do another example
for let's see Seattle verse I'm prompted
for popular rivalry so I'm gonna select
the Rams here and then here you'll see
an answer of an upcoming game on the
17th in addition to web links and this
awesome answer I can also see who being
predicts to win so we're predicting to
the Rams will win food by 51% being uses
search social and other relevant data
signals in order to make predictions on
sports reality TV shows and more and if
I do another really ambiguous search
like set default without any context of
what default I'm trying to set I'm
prompted with very popular things that
people set to false or conversational
search uses large scale machine learning
so this experience is only going to get
better over time
ai learns from user engagement so we're
really excited for the future of
conversational search what I've shown
you today intelligent answers Bing for
business intelligent image search and a
new conversational guided search is just
a small sampling of how we are using AI
to create intelligent search all of
these experiences are either live today
or starting to roll out today